ROB MARTIN: Hello, and
welcome to "Solutions
for Scaling Massive Global
Games in the Cloud".
I'm Rob Martin, Chief Architect
for gaming at Google Cloud.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: And
I'm Sebastian Weigand,
a planet scale systems
architect on Rob's team.
ROB MARTIN: And
today we're going
to be talking a lot
about global games.
First, we're going to define
what we mean by a global game.
Next, we're going to define
all of the components that
are used to power a
global game in the cloud.
Then we're going to do a
demo, and finally, we'll
close out with some thoughts
on a toolkit for building
your own global
game in the cloud.
So let's start by talking
about global games.
Gaming is the world's most
popular form of entertainment,
with 2.7 billion
players globally,
and that number is
expected to increase
by another half-billion by 2023.
Let's talk about an example
of a truly global game.
Apex Legends is a great
example of a truly global game.
Apex Legends launched
exclusively on GCP
with our partner, Multiplay.
Within the first eight
hours after launch,
over a million players
had played the game.
Within the first three
days, that number 10xed
to 10 million players, and by
the end of the first month,
over 50 million players had
joined the fun in Apex Legends.
So let's talk about
concurrency and scaling.
A CCU is defined as
one concurrent player.
Peak CCU is the maximum
number of players
during the day that will be
playing your game all at one
time.
You can see many points of peak
CCU illustrated in the diagrams
to the right.
As players join
your game, you'll
need to scale up infrastructure
to meet that demand.
So in some sense, as
more CCUs join your game,
you'll need to scale up more
CPUs in the cloud to power
the multiplayer experiences.
Let's take a look at a
few different examples
of peak CCUs.
So the first example
is a premium launch
where the game is launched
perhaps at retail,
there's a very large peak
CCU spike on the first day,
and then you settle into
a predictable pattern
in the following days.
Or in the second
example, you might
have a mobile launch where
you have a limited beta,
and then over time,
user acquisition
opens up to add more and
more concurrent players.
What we're seeing
more and more of today
with today's free-to-play
games like Apex Legends
that incorporate content
drops, seasons, and live events
is you're seeing peaks
happening throughout the game's
lifecycle, so in today's
world, it's very important
to be able to scale to
these unpredictable demand
peaks that are generated by
these new types of content
releases.
And so we've talked about
concurrency and scaling.
Now let's talk about geography.
So using an example game with
a million concurrent players,
those players are
going to be distributed
all around the Earth.
Using this example of a
typical AAA PC console game,
we would expect about 40%
of those concurrent players
to be located in North America.
We'd see about 30% of those
players in Europe, about 10%
in South America, and then
the remaining 20% of players
distributed across the
Middle East and Asia.
Now, because latency
matters in gaming,
you're going to need to
deploy your compute resources
all around the Earth
to get them as close as
possible to your players.
So as Seb and I
prepared for this demo,
we thought to
ourselves, would it
be possible to scale up all
of the compute infrastructure
required to run a
global game for one
million concurrent
players within the space
of this 25-minute demo?
What do you think, Seb?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
With the right tools,
anything is possible.
All right, Rob.
Let's dive in.
I've created these
clusters already,
and I've installed
Agones onto each of them.
Right now, these are
essentially empty clusters
running only a few nodes each.
I've got one cluster in the
US, another in the Netherlands,
and a third in Japan.
Because our cloud console
aggregates information
across clusters, I can see that
I don't have anything running
in these clusters yet
besides the pods needed
to run Agones itself.
I've coded up a game server in
Go, which simulates a battle
royale-style game.
It records the events
which typically take place
into BigQuery, our
data warehouse.
It also creates
player information,
such as match rankings,
and writes those
into Spanner, our horizontally
scalable relational database.
To deploy this
server worldwide, we
define it using an Agones
game server fleet spec
combined with a Google Cloud
Game Servers deployment.
The fleet specification looks
just like any other Kubernetes
resource.
Agones provides an abstraction
layer on top of Kubernetes
to understand the
concept of a game server
or a collection of game
servers called a fleet.
It does this
because game servers
aren't your typical
stateless workload.
You don't want your game to get
killed in the middle of a match
and scheduled on another
node, for example.
Likewise, Kubernetes needs
to know more information
about the state that
the game server is
in, such as total player
count, to handle functions
like scaling properly.
Agones takes care of
things like this for us
so that we don't have to.
Let's take a look at
our current fleets
on each of the GKE clusters.
As you can see, we don't
have any fleets deployed.
Let's go ahead and create
a ton of game servers.
To do this, I'm
going to ask GCGS
to apply a new rollout using
the configs I've specified.
What it'll do is connect
to every GKE cluster
in each of the realms and
create the Agones fleets
based upon our fleet spec.
In short, we'll go from
no pods to thousands
across multiple clusters
in multiple continents.
Here you can see the
number of servers
that we want, the number
which we are booting up,
and the number which are ready.
The allocated column
would update once players
start connecting to them.
Rob, you asked about scaling up
enough resources for a million
concurrent players.
Deploying thousands
of these servers
across 10,000 CPU-optimized
cores ought to do the trick.
Let's check those GKE clusters.
Remember, we only had
one node in each zone.
Let's see what it's up to now
that the Cluster Autoscaler has
seen our requests spike.
This is great.
The Cluster
Autoscaler has already
begun adding additional
nodes to these clusters based
upon the resources
that we've requested.
OK, more and more game
servers are coming up.
Agones and GKE are
working together
to spin up additional virtual
machines to handle this load.
This will take just a couple
of minutes to scale up.
Let's check back
in on these later.
Back to you, Rob.
ROB MARTIN: Thanks, Seb.
It'll be interesting
to watch that scale up.
And while that's
happening, let's
talk a little bit about the
components that are required
to power a global game.
So first, you need
a global network
to connect with your players.
Next, you need high-performance
compute to run your simulations
and your multiplayer matches.
Then you need a global
database instance
to track player progress
throughout the game.
You need to monetize
your game, so you'll
need planet scale analytics
that can absorb all the events
you're going to be posting.
And then finally, you need a
fleet orchestrator to bring it
all together, and to scale
this infrastructure up
as players join your game, and
to scale it down as players
move on to other activities.
Let's take a look at each
one of these components
in more detail.
Let's start with
our global network.
The first thing that you'll
notice on this diagram
is the 24 regions
distributed around the globe.
These are represented
as colored circles
and are the
geographies where you
can run your compute resources
to power your matches.
The next thing you'll notice is
our 144 edge points of presence
that are located as close
as possible to your players.
Now, the unique and
differentiated thing
on this diagram is the
fiber optic network
that ties our edge points of
presence and all of our regions
together.
Only Google Cloud offers
a global private fiber
optic network out of the box.
Next let's talk
about compute, which
you'll need to power
your multiplayer matches.
So we know that there are
many different types of games,
from a casual,
mobile title that you
play on your phone with friends
to a powerful and high-fidelity
multiplayer battle royale
match that you play on your PC
or console.
At Google Cloud, we've
created a spectrum of compute
that you can tailor to the
specific needs of your game.
So for that casual
title, you can
run on our cost-optimized VMs,
and for that high-fidelity
battle royal title,
you can run it
on our compute-optimized VMs,
which run at high clock speed
and we built specifically to run
demanding workloads like games.
Next, let's talk about
a scalable database.
As players progress
through your game,
you'll need a way to capture
updates like rankings
and updates to inventory.
The way that a database for a
global game is typically built
is by utilizing a commodity
database like MySQL
and running tens or even
hundreds of instances to power
a global game.
This technique is
not globally scalable
and, from an ops
perspective, is not awesome.
At Google, we offer an
alternative approach
with Spanner, a horizontally
scalable relational database.
We offer the capability to
run a single instance that
can serve all of your players
globally without shards.
Now that's awesome.
So we've talked about a lot
of different infrastructure
components that will be required
to power your global game.
It's going to be important
that you can effectively
monetize, particularly in
today's free-to-play world.
BigQuery offers a globally
scalable data warehouse
that can scale from launch
to the world's biggest games
with zero ops for your team.
Candy Crush is probably
the best example
of scaling running on BigQuery.
Candy Crush ingests
over 70 billion events
per day seamlessly, and
Google manages all the ops.
So to tie it all
together, you'll
need to scale these resources
up and down throughout the day
as players join the game and
move on to other activities.
To manage the scaling of all
of these resources deployed
globally, we built Google Cloud
Game Servers, a global control
plane for running your game.
Google Cloud Game
Servers is built
on top of open
source technology,
including a Agones
and Kubernetes, which
allows you to run
your infrastructure
components wherever you need
them, in GCP, on other clouds,
or on bare metal.
Let's take a closer look.
In this diagram, we're
showing the Game Servers API,
which is your global
API and control
plane for managing your game.
On the left, we have
one Kubernetes cluster
that's running in Google
Cloud platform on GKE.
On the right hand
of the diagram,
we have another
Kubernetes cluster
that's running on
premise, on bare metal.
Both clusters are
being centrally managed
by Google Cloud Game
Servers, and all
of the operational
events and log events
are being captured centrally.
Agones and GCGS offer
a new cloud-native way
to build your game.
Let's talk about the roadmap
for building your game
with this new technology.
First, you
containerize your game
and implement the open
source Agones SDK.
Next, you register
each of your clusters
with the Game Services
API control plane.
Then you begin
organizing your clusters
into groups by geography
that we call realms.
Next, you define configs
for things like autoscaling
policies, and finally, you test
and rollout your game server
binary to your global
fleet of game servers
running on Kubernetes.
So let's check in
on our scaling.
Seb, how do you think
things are looking?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
Pretty good from here.
Let's take a look.
OK, Rob, let's take
a look and see how
our servers are coming along.
So far, we've got 4,200
servers running in the US,
a little over 3,300
running in the EU,
and 500 running in Japan.
This is truly a global
fleet, more than enough
to support one million
concurrent players
as each server can handle
at least 150 players.
It took under eight
minutes to scale up
all the compute needed
for a massive deployment
all around the world.
This really demonstrates just
how easy and powerful managed
Agones really is.
Now let's take a
look at the database.
Here we can see the number
of nodes we're currently
using, along with the CPU
utilization and number
of concurrent requests.
Wow, that's a lot of
requests, and this number
should keep rising as more and
more game servers come online.
We're running about
80,000 queries
per second, which is
about what you would see
for a very large global game.
Should we need to handle more,
rather than deal with database
sharding, we simply increase
the node count in Spanner,
and it handles the rest.
You got to love the separation
of compute and storage.
Now let's check
BigQuery, our gaming data
warehouse where
we've been ingesting
massive quantities
of telemetry events
since we started our fleet.
So far, this table is
just about 100 gigabytes,
with over 800 million rows.
Excellent.
But let's figure out the number
of events processed per second.
Even though there are thousands
of game servers inserting data
right now, let's ask BigQuery
to take the number of events
between the last two minutes
and one minute and then
divide by 60.
What I love about
this is we can keep
inserting more and more data
and let our scalable databases
handle the rest.
When your cloud can scale
to ingest data like this,
your team can focus more on
creating really great games
and less on managing
your infrastructure.
Wow, over 800,000 rows
per second, not bad.
So Rob, in less
than 10 minutes, we
scaled up close to 10,000 cores
of compute on three continents,
wrote over 80,000
inserts per second
to a global database instance,
and ingested over 800 million
rows to our data warehouse.
Talk about scalability.
ROB MARTIN: Wow, those are
some impressive numbers, Seb.
We were able to scale all of
the infrastructure required
for a million concurrent
players in about 10 minutes.
To recap, let's take a look at
each component in this toolbox
for building massive global
games on Google Cloud.
Our premium network
offers a global fiber
optic network that extends your
reach to wherever your players
are around the globe.
Compute-optimized VMs
offer the high clock speeds
required for today's
most demanding games.
Spanner provides a global
database instance for your game
with no sharding.
BigQuery is a planet
scale data warehouse
that can ingest millions or
billions of events each day
for your game.
And finally, Google Cloud Game
Servers, the fleet orchestrator
that can scale these resources
up and down seamlessly
during the day as your
players need them.
To learn more,
join us on the web,
and we'd like to thank
you for joining us today.
So Seb, that was a
pretty cool demo.
We were able to scale
up a million concurrent
player fleet in
about 10 minutes.
So for our viewers,
what would it
take to scale up a fleet for
10 million concurrent players?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Well,
because the infrastructure
and technology are sort of
taking care of it for you,
the only thing that I could
think of would be more quota.